okay so disney star wars run has been
somewhat of a mixed bag completely
splitting the fandom the franchise is
basically developed into marmite where
you either love it or hate it
or you just like this is fine and
although the force awakens got most
people back on board the last jedi is
still a buzzword used to describe
subverting expectations that derails the
franchise in a way that isn't exactly
positive weirdly if we look at the
sequel trilogy it's got this strange
reactionary feeling to it where every
movie seems like it's trying to almost
fix the one that came before it the rise
of skywalker was jj abrams trying to
steer the ship back to the original
outline but if you ask me it's the worst
of the three and just fails on almost
every level book of boba fett split the
fandom obi-wan kenobi is too and outside
of the mandalorian it seems like
everything is getting backlash that's
coming from a guy who actually enjoyed
all that stuff too but i think i'd have
to have my blast shield helmet on to not
admit that there's a big part of the fan
base that hate everything out there no
one hates star wars more than star wars
fans however i thought i'd take a look
at something positive you know heavy
spoilers is all about the love baby and
i thought for once it would be nice to
talk about something disney did right
just just back just back up the money
truck guys come on heavy schillers is
back baby now that is something that we
might all even agree on which is
disney's handling of darth vader search
your feelings you know it to be true
though they've missed the mark on other
things i think that they've really
excelled at breathing and new life into
him and making him arguably even more
intimidating than how he was in the
original trilogy now if you agree with
us throughout the video then please hit
the thumbs up button and make sure you
subscribe for breakdowns like this every
day without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into why
disney's darth vader works so rogue one
was the film that i think slowly started
to lay the groundwork that disney were
upping the ante when it came to the dark
lord of the sith
when we first meet him on mustafar he's
chilling like a villain in his fortress
waiting for the arrival of orson krennic
we're introduced to him in his back to
tank om severed with smoke masking what
he really looks like from here he
travels to meet the imperial and rather
than putting the focus solely on the
director we see how his shadow looms
over him contrasting the black between
his white uniform shadows have been used
throughout the franchise to show
superiority and it's popped up in a lot
of ship scenes in the saga
rally is it used with a person though
and it instantly implies how
intimidating vader is we leave the
camera on him as he walks up to krennic
and we see how he makes him appear much
smaller in stature they did similar
things with bane and ben mendelsohn and
they maybe maybe give the guy a box or
something now though i think him
dropping puns is a bit out of character
i'll let it slide for the meaning behind
this moment krennic is asking if he's
still in charge and vader just wants him
to shut the f up unlike vader krennic
isn't really a likable villain and
because of this you really side with him
telling him to stop talking now this
entrance and how unstoppable it feels is
murdered later on and during the film's
climax we get the death star plan sent
up to the rebel forces and they even
trick us into thinking this is somewhat
of a triumphant moment through the music
used before vader's star destroyer comes
in out of the blue
all ships prepare for jump to hyperspace
using the star destroyer as a battering
ram he mercilessly ploughs through the
rebel ships which look minuscule in
comparison further alluding to this idea
that vader is a powerful giant in
comparison to everyone else even his
soldiers are afraid of him and we see
this in the moment that an imperial
informs him of what's going on
but has received transmissions from the
surface
the air aborting
just looking at this guy's reaction he
breathes a subtle sigh of relief and we
linger on him for just a second to
enforce the idea that everyone is afraid
of vader from here we get one of the
best scenes in star wars and it had my
jaw on the floor the first time i
watched it
[Music]
there's no debating that this is a
standout in the saga and it's one of the
only times that we've ever seen vader
completely off the leash mercilessly
plowing through people
the original trilogy lightsaber fights
are often criticized as being slow and
lumbering and this is why the prequels
did the complete opposite when it came
to their duels however this feels like
an amazing middle ground that doesn't
have the same twirling styles of those
films but it also retains the ferocity
of them
[Music]
the creative team took a simple
environment like a corridor and showed
metaphorically what would happen if
people were trapped in one with a wild
bear having him standing in the darkness
where we just hear his breathing but
can't see him is an incredible way to
introduce him and it's only as his red
lightsaber sparks up that we do finally
see him the guy cuts through them like a
hot lightsaber through butter and it's
one hell of a way to set up the events
of a new hope this movie instantly makes
you want to jump over to that film and i
think it's purely down to how well vader
leaves his mark now another big reason
that vader is so intimidating in the
hands of disney is because they've made
him look like a horror villain directors
doing this is something that we've
discussed in a lot of our videos
recently and it was a technique that
matt reeves used for his version of
batman reeves had the character appear
from the shadows and slowly he walked
towards his prey unshakable and
completely focused this is a motif that
has been used in characters like the
terminator jason voorhees it follows and
michael myers they just slowly walk
towards their target because they don't
need to run they will still catch up to
their victim and this is something that
is seen in vader now if you play jedi
fall in order then you'll know he makes
a major impact in that towards the end
of the game introduced again by his
breathing it completely shakes the
player and is another standout moment
i've carried so much hate for you
vader chases you through fortress
inquisitorius but he never runs he
simply just strolls towards you however
he is a one hit one kill villain that
will instantly end your life if he
manages to catch up to you you aren't
fighting against him you're doing
whatever you can to get away and it was
a smart move by the creative team to
make him the only character that you
can't actually fight people who've
played the game now have the dread in
their mind that he is someone you have
to get away from which translates into
other media now whereas in the case of
the other characters that adopt this
slow pace towards their target they give
vader a practical reason for doing this
in obi-wan kenobi we see him suiting up
and at one point catches synthetic legs
being put on this is the reason he can't
run and is held back but even being a
quadruple amputee he's still the most
powerful character in the show even when
we first see vader in the series it's
his eyes shooting open like a demon
awakening from a dream the guy is
terrifying and disney wants you to think
he's a frankenstein's monstrous creature
of the night this is murder in his
entrance later on which follows a
similar play to rogue one first we hear
his breathing then we get his looming
shadow on the wall before his breathing
is juxtaposed with obi-wan's
whereas ben panics vader's breathing is
slow and steady and at this point they
took it to a place and never thought
they'd go with disney pulling a father
out he chokes him to death in the air
before snapping his son's neck with a
twist of his hands used to be that we'd
only ever see him killing his own men or
the rebels but here they've upped it and
have him brutally murdering civilians
even third sister is shocked and it
perfectly encapsulates how hard the
studio is going with the villain i would
never have expected this from the
character and even comparing him to the
original trilogy he seems sanitized in
that he starts dragging people through
the streets trying to draw obi-wan out
to his compassion and basically just
all over the shop now in the sand i
don't like sand
sorry in the sand amongst the dunes he
sparks a biseba and this angle is also
something that we've seen used before
this is supposed to mirror the moments
before he struck down the younglings in
the jedi temple and he stands there
deliberate unflinching whilst obi-wan
flees vader at this point reveals he
doesn't want to kill obi-wan he just
wants to make him suffer and as we know
fear is the path to the dark side
fear leads to anger anger leads to hate
hate leads to suffering
now he very much just wants to keep him
alive so that he can feel the torment
that he has this is also why he burns
him beta lets him get away because he
wants to prolong his agony and it's
gonna be interesting to see what they do
with the rest of the series and what
they've also done with disney is that
they've managed to hint to his humanity
too which is ultimately what makes him
help his son at the end of return of the
jedi the final season of the clone wars
ended with his apprentice ahsoka evading
the empire's forces after order 66. she
dumped her lightsaber and vader returned
to look for her along with his army of
probe droids and stormtroopers and
amongst the snow he managed to find her
blade very much connects him to his life
before and though he doesn't say
anything the creative team do a lot with
this moment vader due to his mask is
someone who it's very difficult to get
emotion out of however this final shot
is laced with a lot of sadness regret
and also wonder even though he can't see
his face it sets up so much of what's to
come and perfectly lays the groundwork
for the ending and return of the jedi
it's another reason that i think disney
even with their faults have nailed
probably the most important character in
the entire franchise they've got how
intimidating he is of the brutality in
him but also managed to keep the
humanity that ends up turning him around
overall i'm really feeling what they're
doing with him
just just don't let me down guys yeah
at this point the season still has three
episodes left so
apologies if it turns out to be crap now
obviously i'd love to hear whether you
agree whether you disagree and just what
you think we're running a competition
right now and giving away three copies
of the batman on the 15th of june and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the character we pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so if that's you then message
me on twitter at heavyspoilers if you
want some else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of episode 3
which will be linked on screen right now
if not we've got another video there
just in case but hopefully i see over
there right after this without the way
thanks for sticking through this i've
been paul hope to see you next time take
care peace